hey it's evan and today i'm doing
another review
from my fiverr gig where i look at a
website give some feedback
today i've got eight days left to do
this i'm gonna do one for
clinton who's got a website called
itidegroup.com
let's check it out see what it's about
and uh
see what kind of advice we can get so
here's the website
now i don't know anything about this
going in just checking it out
my first thoughts are it looks clean it
looks pretty professional
i'm looking at the top here and you know
i had an issue just saying with the name
so i t
i d e group i tied group
i would split this logo up a little bit
i'm just looking at kind of layout now
let's put that logo up so it's easier to
read i don't get the picture
why we like this is this is in your top
that's that's huge space right there
and then it's on the watermark of your
picture i definitely swapped that out
and doesn't look
very professional but the layout looks
pretty clean pretty easy to read
so what what is this a website all about
learn and earn
trade currency online so the picture
doesn't do anything for me in terms of
learning about
currency but let's see what this is
about welcome to i tied group i see so
much easier right here with the tide
so the little i the capital t capital g
so much easier to read them than this
i tied as a service provider emphasis on
wealth creation through investing in the
foreign exchange exchange market for
actually pride ourselves and helping
people achieve financial success through
trading
so it goes on fx open high tide
difference
quote though no one can go back and make
a brand new start anyone can start from
now and make a brand new ending
that's pretty good i like that quote
successful calls action
three steps help you achieve your
financial goals partner with us today
and then web hosting buy so
you're asking people to make a pretty
important decision right so there's tons
of forex websites out there
there's tons of different markets that
go after why should they choose you
everybody else now this
this looks professional ish uh
again to make this better i would clean
it up like this
has to go unless they're paying you
something but even you know you don't
want that to be on there
that makes it look amateur and again
this at the top and the
captioning and even this picture what's
missing here for me though on a bigger
scale is
is who are you guys right like why
should i go with you over everybody else
give me something that shows the founder
right so who is this person again
clinton clinton where are you
clinton i want to see your face i want
to see the results you've gotten
i want to see testimonials from people
who've gone through your system and it's
worked
that's what i want to see on here make
me
make me feel like you are the right
company to work with like if i go with
clinton
he's the man right i don't get that here
this is a
this is better than some pages out there
but it's it's a lot worse than other
pages and so you're in a super
competitive market you have to do
something to stand out
so overall that's that's my first time
like i would not fill this out
yet because i don't see any social proof
i don't see people having results from
it and i don't know
about who clinton is and why i should
sign up for this so
right like so read this you know okay
the i tied
group difference everything you say here
is something that every other forex
website is going to talk about
we've spent a lot of time developing
this material provide as much value as
possible and although it's only an
iceberg
right everybody talks about this
everybody so you need to do something to
stand out and the way you do that is
through your story clinton
why did you start this what got you into
forex why is it working for you
and what pain did you see in the market
when you went out and
created this website there's a reason
for it right why
why do you want to educate people so
badly that's that's what has to come out
that's how people are gonna
come and sign up with you over everybody
else because
all the other guys are saying exactly
the same thing
so you can make it look more
professional a little bit again it's an
okay job
but still you're gonna have a hard time
i'm betting not a lot of people are
filling this out yet
because you have to tell your store and
make me feel something about your brand
so those are my quick thoughts on the
home page just like a little bit what
else we have here we've got a twitter
page we'll load that up
we've got the facts starting trading our
strategy
so there's nothing about us which i
would love to see i always love to see
who the person is and see a nice smiling
picture of clinton and his success
so here's their twitter page uh so i
guess it's pretty new you know
only 41 tweets but uh what i do like is
it is being updated right sometimes you
go to twitter page there's nothing there
so at least has been updated 21 hours
ago we're posting some quotes from
warren buffett so it's on trend
i'd love to see your face here man you
know make it's called clinton b
if that's your last name b you know have
have your face
make me feel something you know people
love connecting with people that they
see your face and smiling and that's
everywhere that's the part of the brand
people are going to sign up right look
warren buffett it's an
individual people love connecting with
people so switch this around
i love that you're writing to people i
don't know this conversation is all
about
well it's back and forth back and forth
this is great you're like this is
awesome providing supports this guy's
paul have some questions
you know clinton's responding this is
great
right so imagine a paul could interact
with the face here
so you're doing the right thing so far
on twitter this is great you're
responding to people you're posting
quotes and some interesting information
look at all these app responses
this is great so
back to the website these are the three
pages the facts are trading our strategy
again i would
change all of this out take this off
change the picture
get rid of this thing it doesn't relate
to what you're talking about here
the font is nice though the contents
nice
the layout looks good you're asking some
questions
again this could be so much better if
you made this
personal so okay let's see what is forex
oh
ideally this is a link or take me right
down to it but let's go to what is forex
so for example this is you know these
questions
again it's gonna be from every single
person who has a forex website
right what is forex what is a pip what
are the seven most commonly traded
currencies
so i mean i can find this everywhere
what's going to make the big difference
is your take on it
right how to trade foreign exchange over
the internet
so so you're talking about metatrader4 i
don't know anything any i don't know
anything about this right metatrader4
fx open tell me why you love this
why is metatrader4 the best thing ever
why is fx open your favorite tool to use
right
tell me your story say tell me about the
the other forex
systems you've used that sucked and how
cumbersome they were and expensive and
terrible service or whatever the points
are and say why you love working with
this because this is just facts and i'm
getting lost in it
it's not making me feel anything where
if you came up until it told your story
and told me why you picked metatrader4
why this is important that i should care
about it then i'm going to be more
interested
and that personal connection is going to
bond me to you and when you make a
recommendation i'm trusting you as the
expert
so i'm going to listen so you're close
you've got a lot of the
a lot of the great information here you
just need to tweak it and make it more
personal
next this is start trading same thing
out out fix
act today trade tomorrow getting started
is simple just a question
so here we're talking again about the
the systems
this is great that you have it you know
the steps
pictures i love all that activate
uh it would be great to have something
here about
contacting you if you have any questions
to support like what if this doesn't
work for me
there's a way to reach out if it's on
twitter or email
i love that you're you have this is i
don't know what this is a filter
contact us to send you the filter i mean
this is great you have a a lead capture
form here
so people have a way to write in you're
not just losing everybody who can bounce
but i think the missing step here is
first again talking about why you picked
this system
and then also having a way for people to
reach out to you and ask you questions
if they have about it
and the last our strategy same thing top
top picture out
you know to make more money you need a
strategy chart set up
so i'm guessing it's a very technical
system which is fine
when to stay out this is great
so like where does the strategy come
from is this your strategy our focus on
strategy is it
so tell me the results from this tell me
how you came up with this
show me students who've had success with
this right you put that on the board
before you get into the technical
details of how something works
make me feel that it's important because
otherwise my eyes are going to gloss
over
but if you tell me your story how you
came up with it you showed me students
who are having a lot of success with it
i'm much more likely to pay attention
i guess that's the end of the page so
overall it's a good start
my general thoughts again uh
professional ish could be made better
with some of the things we talked about
make it more personal
make me feel something touch me with
your story
you do that you'll have a much higher
conversion rate you have people wanting
to share this website
and i'd also add some more information
beyond these three pages
right so you can have an about me page
you can have a blog
some thought leadership content like
show me that you're the expert that you
know what you're talking about and
you're having success with this show me
some of your trades
whatever it is show something ongoing to
make me say you know what clinton b
that dude is the forex king and i need
to be following him
those are my thoughts for those of you
watching let me know what you think
leave a comment underneath
let me know what your thoughts are about
this website and i'm sure clinton would
enjoy it as well
if you guys like this video thumbs up
below you can click on my face at the
upper right corner to subscribe to the
channel
thank you guys so much i'll see you soon